J'sais pas ce qu'il m'arrive !!
Depuis maintenant deux mois, ma vie est devenue un enfer.
Je suis comme traqué par elle
J'ai d'abord pensé que ça pouvait m'être utile.
Mais... non. J'en peux plus.J'en peux plus.
Comédien.
Les amis souvenez-vous j'avais fait une vidéo où je vous expliquait
un problème que j'avais, et que beaucoup de gens ont, à savoir la rage sur les jeux videos
et depuis que je joue a For Honor c'est encore pire qu'avant
Depuis 2 mois j'ai un problème colossal
tu vois il est ça fois 10 le problème
Il est.. c'est chaud!
Dès que je touche un objet métallique
Je me prends une décharge mon gars
Mais comme la cloture qui garde les vaches quoi
Et alors au début ça m'amusait je me disais "waouh! p*tain"
Je me prends de gros coups de jus.
Et au bout de deux heures... T'en as marre!
Quand je lances la caméra je me prends un coup de jus.
Avec le casque Coca-Cola, d'une grande qualité, j'me suis même pris un coup de jus dans l'oreille la dernière fois.
Bon ça c'était juste parce que le casque était un peu chelou.
Quand j'ouvre une porte! Ça: ça devient ton pire ennemi!
Le bouton pour appeler l’ascenceur !
*Rires*
Désolé. Je cries mais franchement pour une fois c'est justifié
Là vraiment!
Je ne sais pas si certains d'entre vous ont ce problème mais sa fait deux moi que je suis éléctrique.
J'pensais au début que j'avais vraiment un superpouvoir
J'me disais : putain j'vais résilier mon contrat avec edf
vas-y j'peux créer moi-même l’électricité, chuis un ouf chuis un thug
Non ! J'me la prend juste l'électricité
j'la crées pas !
C'est juste un pouvoir nul,voilà, où t'es un peu électrique
mais pas trop ! Je m'suis alors mis à développer
des techniques, pour ne plus être surpris
par le fait de recevoir un coup d'électricité en touchant quelque chose.
Technique n°1 !
Il faut un pull, c'qui n'est pas le cas...
Voilà, effets spéciaux.
Ta peau de babtou bien blanche ne doit surtout pas entrer en contact avec cet objet.
Tu vas donc l'ouvrir avec le coude !
Et perdre tout tes amis qui te prendront pour un profond demeuré.
Et c'est là qu'intervient la deuxième technique que j'ai mise au point :
celle que tu utilises...
quand tu es en t-shirt à manches courtes.
La surprise.
C'est la pire de toutes car tu ne passes plus pour un profond demeuré...
mais pour un profond demeuré à tendances psychopathes
-Tu viens pas ? - Non, j'vais passer par la fenêtre dans le doute.
Les gens me fuient ! Ils ont peur de moi !
Je sais très bien que si certains d'entre vous ont ce problème, vous avez développé les deux mêmes techniques :
le coude ou le petit coup qui fait qu'tu seras moins surpris par la décharge.
Je m'suis même mis à avoir mal à la tête
au moment où j'vais toucher un objet métallique
parce que j'me concentre pour pas être surpris par la décharge.
Je pense que c'est un problème d'installation edf,
on va les appeler.
"Si vous avez déjà un contrat edf,"
"tapez 1 sinon..."
"merci de taper votre numéro client..."
"qui se trouve dans la rubrique..."
"si vous n'avez pas accès à votre facture..."
"tapez 0"
-Edf, Jean-Sébastien, bonjour.
-Bonjour, j'vous appelle parce que j'pense qu'il y a un problème avec vos installations,
dès qu'je touche un objet en métal, je me prend une grosse décharge.
-Ah, alors c'est effectivement pas normal.
-Voilà donc c'est désagréable, j'ai fait plusieurs malaises déjà et ça me, euh, ça m'tiraille.
-Euh ça se produit depuis quand ?
-Depuis deux mois environ quand je touche une poignée, un pc, n'importe quoi, un objet métallique je m'prend une décharge.
-Ouais... Et vous avez fait vérifier l'installation intérieure ?
-Euh oui ! Déjà oui, on m'a dis que tout était normal donc j'comprend pas trop.
-Euh c'est pas normal là, on vous a dis que c'est normal mais si vous prenez des décharges c'est que c'est un problème de terre.
-Et c'est comme de l'électricité statique : d'un coup j'me prend un... un p'tit coup quoi
et des mais m'ont dis que ça venais de chez vous.
-Oui... bah c'est possible, ça peut arriver...
-D'accord, bon et du coup est-ce que vous avez des solutions ?
-Non euh, j'vous conseille de faire attention.
"J'n'ai aucune peine, j'te nique ta raaaace !"
-Est-ce qu'éventuellement si j'mets mes mains dans des chaussettes pour toucher des objets métalliques, je n'aurai plus de problèmes ?
-Euh ça peut être une solution oui.
-D'accord. Plutôt soquettes ou chaussettes de ski du coup ?
-Euh ce que vous avez sous la main j'vous conseille.
-D'accord alors ça sera des p'tites soquettes. Bah merci de votre aide c'est vraiment sympa.
-Je vous en prie. -Au revoir. - Bonne fin de journée.
Mais putain ! Mais tu crois qu'e vais passer la fin de ma vie avec des chaussettes aux mains ?!
Mais il va pas bien ce gars !
Et ça marche ! Merci Edf !
Bon j'en ai parlé autour de moi :
Bruce, d'E-penser, vie le même calvaire,
le grand JD vie le même calvaire,
est-ce qu'il y a une association pour aider les gens qui ce font électrocuter régulièrement tout le temps ?
Association des gens qui se prennent une décharge dès qu'il touche un objet métallique.
ça ça n'a rien à voir.
Est-ce que quelqu'un, un jour, aurai une réponse ?
Aidez moi, s'il vous plait, I need some help, s'il vous plait quelqu'un ?
-Un problème Squeezie ? -Ouais j'arrête pas de me prendre des décharges !
-Ah alors figure toi que quand tu te prend des décharges c'est à cause de l'électricité statique.
et d'ailleurs ces décharges portent un nom, on les appelle des :
décharges électro-statiques.
Bon ce qu'il faut ce rappeler c'est comment c'est foutu un atome.
Y a un noyau composé de neutrons et de protons
et des électrons qui gravitent autour de ce noyau.
-Electra j'connais ouais.
Et le truc c'est que lors de chaque contact, lors de chaque frottements avec une surface,
quand tu enfiles un pull, quand tu frottes une serviette, quand tu marches pieds nus sur la moquette
ou quand tu enfiles un slip en laine, me dis pas qu'ça arrives jamais,
et bien parfois on arrache de ces électrons alors
l'électricité s'accumule dans ton corps et deviens plus riche en électrons
il est donc chargé négativement
et ensuite lorsque tu touches une surface chargée positivement
il y a ce petit choc électrique que toi tu sembles ressentir assez souvent,
ce choc correspond au transfert d'électrons d'un milieu à un autre
alors j'avoues ça pique un p'tit peu, on peux pas y faire grand chose : lorsqu'il y a un transfert d'électrons d'un milieu chargé négativement à un milieu chargé positivement  TAC
décharge, c'est précisement ça que tu ressens
bon et dans l'ensemble, pourquoi ça t'arrive surtout depuis deux mois, la réponse : l'hiver
-Aaaah avant l'printemps ouais.
-ça a plus tendance à arriver en hiver qu'en été parce qu'en hiver les conditions météorologiques favorisent cette circulation électrique,
donc on a plus tendance à se tac !  prendre des coups de jus.
Voilà, salut mec ! -Salut !
Nozman tu viens effectivement d'éclairer ma lanterne .
On retourne dans un camion maintenant.
Et bien les amis, c'est la fin d'la vidéo si vous vivez le même calvaire que moi n'hésitez pas à aimez la vidéo ou alors il faut s'soutenir parce qu'y a pas d'solutions d'toutes manières.
Enfin edf m'en a conseillé une mais chuis pas très chaud.
Pecho avec des chaussettes aux mains c'est... starfoullah t'es fort.
Merci Nozman pour ces expliquations.
"klaxon"
bon la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'y a pas d'solutions mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que maintenant je comprends ce qui s'passe
quand j'me prend un coup d'jus.
Cette vidéo va encore durer encore très longtemps puisque j'ai peur d'appuyer sur l'écran pour arrêter le rec... J'en flippe.
Aujourd'hui j'm'en suis pas trop pris encore, j'pense qu'il y a vraiment une chance encore que j'm'en prenne un.
Attends du coup j'ai peur, j'fais une paranoïa vas-y... Attention moment d'vérité !
C'est bon ! J'm'en suis pas pris putain !